AGAINST ANTON FORSBERG,
STEERED AROUNDOFF.
FOR NUMBER
AGAINST TOROPCHENKO NOW BUCHNEV.
IT THIS TIME BLOCKER SIDE.
TWO GOAL POSTS FOR OTTAWA AND
NOW THE SENATORSDY TKACHUK DOES
A GOOD JOB SHIELDING THE PUCK
B!
PERRON OF
THE AIR?
DOES IT AGAIN AND
STRAIGHT AND THEY'VE GETS IT BAE
HERE, THE ST. LOUIS BLUES DOING
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
RIGHT HERE, THOUGH,HOUNDED.
THE SENATORS FORECHECKING WITH
TWO GUYS AT A TIME HERE REALLY
HARD ON THE PUCK.YEAH, NO. A BA
THERE BY JORDAN BINNINGTON JUST
PAUL LET IT GO.
NOW PLAY.
YOU HAVE TO WATCH HIM.
>> Joh
TKACHUK, HE WAS WIDE OPEN.
NORRIS AGAIN, DROPS IT O FORSBE
GREAT JOB SWALLOWING UP THE
OT
AREAS HERE AND THE EL
BELL I SHALLS A LITTLE BIT BUT
NONETHELESS GETTING OVER THERE
AND KEEPING THE PUCK OUT OF THE
NET.
>> John: FAULK, HE WALKS DUMP-I
TONIGHT.
OTTAWA BREAKS IT UP AND BRADY T
SNEAKS BEHIND AND WATCH WITH AN.
SCHENNER'S HAD A COUPLE
LITTLE PASS UP HERE, BACKHAND
THROUGH THE MIDDLE OF THE ICE,
USUALLY NOT ADVISED BY T DYLAN .
HERE'S MIKKOLA ON TO SCHENN.
NEVER REALLY GOT THE PASS.
AND HE ISABSOLUTELY.
THE CLOCK IS THE ENEMY RIGHT
NOW. EXTRA ATTACKER.
AS O'REILLY
BEHIND BY A COUPLE OF GOALS AND
YOU'VE GOT TO FORCE THE
FORSBERG AROUND, AND OTTAWA IT